لا تفكروا كثيرا هو بالفعل كما تظنون جرذ
عملاق صوره احد السياح تحت ابرز معالم
اوروبا جمالا وسحرا برج ايفل في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس التي تعاني من غزو الجرذان
حتى ان احدها دخل في معطف هذه السيده خلال
مقابله تلفزيونيه
في فيلم الرسوم المتحركه راتتوي او الفار
الطباخ والحائز على جائزه اوسكار تقترب
الفئران كثيرا من البشر حتى انها تبتكر
وصفه طعام تلقى اعجاب الجميع وربما هذا ما
قصدته رئيسه بلديه باريس التي اثارت موجه
جدل كبيره عندما قالت ان الحل لانتشار
الجرذان هو التعايش معها
لدي مقترح لتشكيل لجنه لاستكشاف ما اذا
كان ينبغي على المواطنين في العاصمه باريس
ان يتعلموا التعايش السلمي الى جانب
الفئران بدلا من محاوله القضاء عليها سنضع
موقعا الكترونيا لمساعده السكان على
القيام ببعض التقنيات بخصوص ذلك لننظر الى
نيويورك وكيف يتم التعامل مع الامر
يعيش في باريس عاصمه الجمال والموضه
والانوار مليون انسان ونحو خمسه ملايين
جوردن باتت تشكل هاجسا يوميا للسكان لا
سيما عندما يتذكرون انها كانت سببا في
الطاعون الاسود الذي ضرب اوروبا في القرن
الرابع عشر وقتل ثلث سكانها في بضعه اعوام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات